city
by any so high level things above
what then
I am talking about monotheism or
polytheism
that's my debate if there's anyone was
suggesting no no no that's one argument
has more because none of you know why
you know why no because the thing is you
guys claim your money fistic but I
believe you're monotheistic that's the
debate I want to have if you want to you
just said we were facing
yes we are no I believe you're poly fist
okay my evidence is basically that okay
good good good good okay yeah yeah what
I told you we have Towe Heat yeah we
have a principle that we well I prove my
first me I don't have a religion to
myself yeah that's one good any let me
finish
yeah I we believe in a principle called
so he'd yet enola here unless my I know
here no idea I don't know he ran a small
was a fad it's worship singling out God
in what he does meaning all power and
knowledge is with Allah yes we single
out God in worship meaning we worship
God invited or not the Prophet Mohammed
not Jesus most statues
no trees or nothing will come to that
will come to them the third point is his
names and attributes he's got many names
actually the most merciful the most
powerful the most knowing now i i'm i'm
just going to prove to you while you're
polytheistic based on this standard
based on the stance of Islam yeah okay
because you need to understand when when
people eat God Almighty is the most
powerful course okay he's all-powerful
yeah okay does he share his power with
anything else
No so the Holy Spirit and Jesus that's
not sharing how is that why is that then
that's not sharing okay so when Jesus is
gonna be glorified next to the father on
the day of the end of times true God's
in the same place on his left-hand side
one God three persons okay okay when
Jesus when Jesus is being glorified next
to the Father how many beans are one
being okay okay God and Jesus being
glorified next a good next two not with
next to let me see yes on the right hand
side of will you be glorified that's not
next to us thus thus thus referring to
Authority and power so nothing to
radiation but do you understand my point
how are you sign your point you're
saying next - okay so if he's going to
be there or with authority and power we
believe the ultimate authority and power
knowledge is we've got not with Jesus
Jesus yeah so then when they say Jesus
would be glorified next to the Father
why did they say Jesus will be glorified
on his own because God is love and four
gods exist in love much but in love but
it connects me yeah love cannot exist on
its own
in his nature love past the love and
objects that's some money let me explain
so love was eternal eternal in the
beginning love coexisted between the
Father Son Holy Spirit do you need to do
that again it coexists between the
Father Son Holy Spirit yeah so him God
loving you is unconditional because it
was eternal
yeah so that's why it was between the
Father Son Holy Spirit but I learned the
other side if he is loving who was he
loving before he created anyone what we
see is what you're asking is good needs
like another beam fill of God
okay we believe God is it doesn't need
anything he's free from any meeting yes
it's within himself [ __ ] of he loves
s not mother son Holy Spirit is within
himself
yeah that's love that's eternal okay but
when you said Jesus will be next to the
god with authority and power we believe
what you're telling me is God sharing
the power sure not about to me to me you
need to understand look look pure and
what that's within the divinity about
why money why I believe were money
physic and you're not because we believe
in a robe appear sinking in out God in
what he does is all-powerful he does
everything according to himself he
doesn't need another person coming and
moving this or that he doesn't answer
Allah has other people coming unless a
pre-islamic God it's not an Islamic
that's that's another topic the fingers
you need to prove that God okay in Islam
do me not worship God I'm gonna no no
okay where's evidence for this around
four sixty four sixty okay redo please
take it out
I don't know how to operate it
Oh
just do this and then go here and go to
the karana
yeah yeah just press can choose which
yeah yeah we did not send any messenger
but to be obeyed by the leave of Allah
have a after day after having wronged
themselves come to you and sought
forgiveness from Allah and had the
messenger prayed for the forgiveness
they will certainly have found Allah
most relenting various contexts yeah so
never by your lord never shall they
become believers unless they make you
judge in the disputes that arise between
them then find no discomfort in their
hearts against what you have decided and
surrender to it in total submission a
lie saying they have to submit to you or
going to become proper believers okay so
what's the problem in Allah and Muhammad
yeah they're partners okay all right
show you more so basically what you're
seeing is Allah says obey me and obey
the messenger until they make you a
judge between you that basically they're
not true believers - yeah and that means
that they are allies basically to submit
to them equally okay good okay so
basically what you're trying to see here
to show you the tafseer of allah oh my
did because why this verse came down you
know even if iike this and why this
verse came now Omar cut the neck off
okay some guy who disagreed with
Mohammed okay that's that's that's also
conscious what you're talking about
well let's get to the topic let's stick
to the topic yeah let's get Lester
Lester okay okay
but what I'm saying is this thing listen
to the topic yeah you said that because
it's rivers okay yeah you can close it
by later
yeah okay so what you're trying to say
is that God Almighty has a partner
because he said you need to well worship
me and obey the messenger yes yeah they
have to submit to him no think finding
in themselves to disobey no you can't
criticize mom okay alright okay
basically what you're seeing basically
what you're saying is that because of
this Mohammed is a good hit okay so let
me disprove that because what that means
is God Almighty says obey me and obey
the messenger let the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him tell us to worship
Allah and Allah alone Muhammad himself
yeah Muhammad himself said it yeah okay
all right so when we obey mean that does
that mean is got it this is beautiful
because because the reason why people
are killing when maha when you criticize
Muhammad is because they seem us god I
think that's too much television no
that's too much TV that's even kaffir
I'm giving you even kaffir go into
propaganda I'm asking a question you see
a link in it on the side note listen
there's a lot of Christians killing
Muslims Buffs ear I'm telling you do we
not as Muslims worship the God Almighty
by obeying the messenger okay okay okay
did the Prophet Muhammad tell us to
worship Allah and all alone yes he did
the Prophet Muhammad has passed away now
yeah so today do we worship Allah alone
yes we do so we obey don't one second
I'm telling you is there anyone that
goes and prays show me one Muslim that
says O Muhammad please give me this
water stir shampooed tashahud
is praising the prophet meal it mentions
Muhammad's name in your prayers of
course we do be crazy the Prophet peace
of when we pray for him the doors are
brought forth to him yes one chalice
hits you is do you if your father passed
away if you prayed for him does that
mean you worship I don't pray for him
okay if you said the guys dead not him
me I pray to God okay no no but was it
wasn't you understand yeah that's what
it isn't good you should do that
no you're missing the point the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him if I praise
him and say he was a mightiest messenger
is that worship in the in the in the
press in your prayers in the pray if I'm
saying peace be upon him and his family
that you say Oh peace be upon you
Muhammad okay okay okay whatever you say
if I go and pray for my dad and say Oh
God no one second longer for my dad once
I wasn't one second if I'm saying may
peace be upon you I'm asking God to send
peace upon him yes we are okay if you're
saying if you'll say that to me
god forbid yeah what if you die and I
say Oh peace be a point what's your name
Oh peace be upon you Ali I'm not
directly talking to understand your
point if I am sending peace be upon the
Prophet Muhammad Moses Abraham I'm
praising asking God fulfill mercy upon
them how is the worship this is how you
do it you say you know you know you know
I love ya Ya Allah I ask you yes for
peace to be raid on a Muhammad you don't
say ask you ask me you ask him so in
Salah
incident in Salah Who am I printed both
of them even the sisters were shocked
yeah that's true that's an evidence of
course the guys when we pray were
praying to Allah and Allah knows yay
permission listen listen
we are brothers any chance we can use
that for the camera like if you stand
next to it now if you stand next to it
before the camera here so I said yeah no
no no no what you're missing something
praying is what you guys do which is
over here that's the second part men
should not do you know you know pretty
good our praise to God in the name of in
the name of in the main man Jesus is God
brother one second okay no God
so you can't listen you you gave me a
verse being that we worship the Prophet
Muhammad because Allah said obey me and
obey the messenger okay listen listen
all you're doing is doing propaganda
listen listen let me make a point can I
make my point
I'm telling you go Tom I said obey me
and obey the messenger
do you know didn't the Prophet told us
or worship Allah Allah alone did you
know say that okay once again okay if he
taught us to worship Allah and Allah
alone
do we not obey the messenger through
that by implementing doesn't it say a
proper believer they have to submit to
you in what in what in what in what in
what to become what in what would you
mean you want once again we need to
submit him in what would you be reward
in judgment yeah okay so if somebody
comes and the Prophet madman comes into
the judge between us whatever he says we
obey that how does that mean worship
brother you can't just submit to him if
he's wrong one second who said he's
wrong wrong you said wasn't you have
where did alone simple Alice wants Allah
said indeed if the Prophet madman said
anything of himself we would have
grabbed him from his jugular vein and
cut it or grab it so they found that
good the fact that it says that shows us
that weak weaker when I got that's
another topic my brother no no but no no
no no no no I'm giving you full take I'm
giving you context yeah so when it comes
to Aruba beer
we worship then we single out God
Almighty what he does we don't say he
needs Jesus or Muhammad to make powers
we don't we don't work I can expand the
story won't let it expand this topic
with more verses you be more verses you
can give more verses but what you're
missing here is this we worship God
Almighty alone and we we look at this
mess you clean mess your claims later
listen listen listen show me show me a
single Muslim that does that none so
what I'm trying to do that goes and says
yo Muhammad I just showed you the touch
my brother my brother my brother look
you can give real take my party me
scriptures all day
Knight you're missing joy you're missing
the point
so the point here is this he seen you
worship Muhammad why because Allah said
obey me and obey the messenger two four
six eight
so this is the evidence is bringing he's
saying that we worship Him because we
have to obey so so do you do you for
example when Moses came down with
Commandments and those who obeyed him
are they worship in Moses no it's got
nothing to do with that it's hard
didn't Moses come down with Commandments
these are prophets did he not come on
commandment he came back oh man if
anyone he never said obey me submit to
me without finding anything inside you
to criticize it was improper believers
you never said if anyone rejects the
commandments why they do it
I need this will be Moses of course the
commandments of God
okay thank you you're not disobeying the
commandments of Franco mama so Mohammed
bang
that's why Omar cut the neck question
someone who disagree with the guy what
you doing is you just go in a propaganda
you keep talking about killing it's
simple Moses came with Commandments if
Moses if anyone disobeys Moses
Commandments it's like you disobeying
God Almighty it's the same with the
Quran the Prophet came with a revelation
anyone that disobeys that they're not
only this will being the message this
you being a lot because I was in those
revelation so that's why you do not
single out good in what he does what you
do is you give power other people like
you said or further to empower Jesus
shares it with God I didn't say you said
he's gonna clarify so he's good himself
then why'd he prayed to the Father
sorry why do you pray to the Father
because yours - well thank you okay
let's give this person go go to Beatrice
that's what a polytheistic but you
understand you know what's funny with
our Christian friends they think it's a
ability for God could come and have a
few there go look that's an ability God
can do that I think it's something good
it's so sad you can't [ __ ] of opinion
he did I'm gonna dip you okay I'll do
that
no he did what I promised his majesty
I'm better than okay okay can God lie
that's not in his nature
why because once again do it it wasn't
important in his nature and stuff a lot
but line is not no becoming a human yeah
you can do that Michael like that's the
devil okay
we give the strength of another verse
yeah answered that question say your
prophet if you really love Allah then
follow me and Allah shall love you and
forgive you your sins a lot most
forgiving and most merciful say obey
Allah and the messenger this is
separation okay I forgot the Arabic word
there and the messenger yes Wow
yeah that's a number what is what mean
in Arabic partnership trust me is
partnership going to trust me I don't
know I repeat my trust go check with
Arabic scholars don't trust me sit this
is he obey Allah does not love the obey
Allah and obey the messenger and the
messenger
what did the message you see worship
Allah Allah your baby now so do we obey
mean that you do not want us more
there's one giving you an argument very
on that you understand argue miss Mary
I'm going beyond that look you know
right but you don't understand I never
pee again
the I love did Allah say obey me and the
messenger did the messenger say worship
Allah alone yes do we worship you do we
do we agree or do we do we acknowledge
him in that and do that yes that's your
argument
we worship Allah caused the Prophet told
us and we submit to the Prophet that's
it
that's look that argument is not gonna
carry the honor for them we let them
decide okay now the second reason why I
believe your policies that can I show
you another verse another you saw off
your country sir of 53 19 to 21 who are
they
who still go and that's pre-islamic god
no it's that they all had a lot my Brava
woody statues sorry woody statue yeah
did the Prophet destroy them he actually
affirmed them I can show you the
scriptures yeah I must confirm them and
then he listen this is nobody under 60
okay let me get this right the Prophet
God's good from there and any when and
destroyed his good Nora he affirmed them
he affirmed he the perfect destroy used
he used that part okay
for worship I'm asking ya did the
Prophet go into the Kaaba and destroy
the statues yeah so he destroyed the
destroy the gods okay our debate our
debate today here is it's Christianity
monotheism of polytheism it's not as
well that's why me and I were debated
point you a robo beer we single out God
in what he does or power and majesty all
knowledge and knowledge belongs to him
yeah he has power with himself
possession with Jesus or Mohammed and
only here worshipping singling out Allah
ya know this with me yeah okay the
second point the second point is a loner
here singling out let me tell you why
you're polytheistic yeah because anytime
we have some code I don't know here
singling out in worship meaning when I
worship I worship God and God alone
Muhammad not Jesus no statue do you okay
I know it's funny our bluff is wrong
with what you're telling me now do you
worship God
yes in the name of Jesus
okay so if and I explained that to you
yeah using the analogy of love what's it
yeah the love doesn't mean Jesus people
always come and say Allah loving yes he
is always he loved him before he created
anyone what do you mean no he loved it
yeah he had the attribute
no it doesn't know he's the own living
yeah but you have to love something no
no your turn that's your turn no it's
your turn
do you want you to mess that's your turn
now when it comes when it comes
and over here we this is why one money
fishy because we worship God alone you
would never see a Muslim a true Muslim
saying O Muhammad ask Allah oh Jesus but
why do you pray to God in the name of
Jesus because because Jesus Christ is
God okay
Father Son Holy Spirit there one being
three persons and when Jesus went to the
Mount of Gethsemane and breathe who was
he bring the father my agent neither
father
so he's this I'm not good no I didn't
say that I I'm explaining to you but all
your thinking the father's the only good
but all your thinking the father's the
only God
I'm not saying down didn't you say three
persons one being one second you pray in
the name of Jesus to Vanya
you pray in the name of Jesus yeah when
Jesus went to the Mount of Gethsemane
and fell on his face did he say Oh in
the name of myself no he did my father
explained to the father because he was a
human being and God at the same time yes
I did need to go so he was a human being
and God at the same time in his human
nature he prayed to the Father okay
in Islam we don't believe in this look
you have a right to believe that this is
one of the second reasons why you're a
polytheistic because you okay okay okay
look you've brought your argument for
him as a human what is also going divine
attribute we let the viewers decide
because no point are scary for the third
part the third point I smell was the
father names and attributes
do you believe girls were powerful and
all knowing yeah okay when Jesus go to
the last days he was a human being and
God at the same time when Jesus was on
the cross what happened to his power
like so why did he allow the creation
that he created the stone him because of
you and I because of our sins you know
what happened to his power not why he
did it
I'm asking what happened to his powers
Jim opened his powers easy easy
his powers aside so that he can die and
resurrect so as a sacrificial love one
second are you telling me it's it he set
his powers go on holiday I'm strong
because no how did listen this the
father
there's the Son and the Holy Spirit the
father didn't die the spirit didn't die
okay I died okay one second yeah oh one
second but he still exists okay but for
example look number one if he was
all-powerful he would not allow his
powers he can't see oh I'm gonna take my
power out there you go if he was
powerful
get away and bring her back no no no
because just you know just okay can
cause like I told you okay true okay so
for example he says like one second he
says it's not in the nature of God to
lie by seeing the nature of God to take
his power away from him and
he can't come down here no no no no but
you need to understand you I'm saying
goodbye you see any cons I'm talking
about nature one scene is in his nature
he can't like yeah but so I'm Sifu evil
are you saying it become look is it
doesn't suit God's majesty because
you're saying it becomes a man
how will you glorify God by saying he
came in with Twitter because he comes
and relates with you that's God no you
can relate with you this isn't I'm
that's like oh for sure love I make a
chair I don't need to become a chain to
relate with the chair there can't talk
to you listen we're relational listen
listen so God comes delicious listen
like a cellulation like I said before
you were saying three-in-one the Father
the Son and Holy Spirit one in essence
monotheism yeah a ghost if a religion
came and said 600 gods one in essence
you say polytheism you're good you're
going against the principle of greatness
and it said God create is it that way
look look look look at Islam Bodi know
the holy spirit if you are already
bodies never make it simple for you
worship God alone no ask me this louder
listen 101 worship but alone worship
when along Jews they knew they knew see
even then why don't they follow it
would you what is in the juice follow it
who's Isaiah was according to you know
who are the Jews are feeding the Jews
today's they also believe it there are
some who don't they saw which you
believe vomiting I wasn't in you would
you believe we're no Jewish people that
believer but yes show me one
here I'll come to you thank you whatever
you like take my number my dress how
come I want to see that June hope you do